assimilation et intégration assimilation
basse prodige
individus souveraine européenne
on soigne
voilà je vous prête à jouer
saccage
tout petits muscles
optimiste pour les présidentielles je
pense qu'on va largement gagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au prix la ministre
rien à l'horizon
andré fabre
[Musique]
il est sauvé
il ya des années
[Musique]
robert hanssen salut
[Applaudissements]
très bon meeting beaucoup de monde qui
était attendu la salle était remplie une
énergie vraiment militante à hyper
impressionnante et puis c'est mon fidèle
à lui-même deux heures sans notes c'est
impressionnant
c'était assez naturel de rejoindre les
républicains puisque encore une fois mon
père avait voté sarkozy et j'avais une
image très positive du parti des
républicains c'était pour moi le parti
de droite par excellence
[Musique]
eric zemmour est donc annulée à ce
moment là dans ma vie c'était comme
quelque chose qu'on avait toujours
attendus un homme politique servi sur un
plateau d'argent pour la droite
on est en train de faire du tractage
devant l'université de la catho à lille
aujourd'hui on essaye vraiment de
mobiliser la jeunesse parce que c'est
cinquante deux pour cent d'entre eux qui
ne vote pas au bruit donc on essaye de
les inciter à aller voter et à se
renseigner sur le programme des risées
mans sur le programme de monsieur
zemmour comme ça un peu un peu raciste
en fait parce que j'ai déjà vu plusieurs
fois dans des programmes tv notamment
dans des débats et c'est alain muet et
je trouve qu'ils stigmatisent beaucoup 3
en fait les minorités en france tels que
les musulmans il se bat contre
l'islamisation de la france l'islam une
islamisation de la france moi quand
j'entends vos débats sur une
islamisation comme si c'était horrible
on dirait que vous parlez de terrorisme
ce n'est pas le cas on est d'accord
alors que l'effet d'amalgamé ce que
demande le jeune et amis en train de
lever parce que tout le monde parle
comme si l'islamisation fait est grave
l'islamisation si les gens veulent vivre
dans leur vie
pas toutes dans la rue c'est ça la
france franchement c'est à la prendre
ils vont interdire l'idéologie lgbt dans
les classes d'école l'idéologie ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe soumet ce sont
des lobbies qui sillage des lobbys lgbt
ça n'existe ici alors on s'agace il y en
a
eu des lgbt ce qu'ils véhiculent par
exemple l'identité de genre à des
enfants lyon 5 6 ans 7 8 ans alors que
c'est des questions qui devraient pas
les toucher est ce que eric élever nos
problèmes on a le droit de l'éducation
elle ajouté je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
s'est très bien passé on a vraiment eu
de la chance parce qu'on a plus
justement expliqué nos arguments et
débattre avec des gens qui partagent des
panneaux point de vue ça se passe
malheureusement pas tout tant que sales
habitudes
plus agressifs qu'ils sont moins
coopératifs
par la communication politique sur les
réseaux sociaux en fait on permet déjà
de démocratiser la politique chez eric
zemmour on a des postes qui sont parfois
très simpliste mais qui ont beaucoup de
chance et qui permettent de toucher le
plus de monde possible parce que les
gens comprennent pas ce que ça leur
parle du coup ça rend la politique
beaucoup plus sympathique et encore une
fois beaucoup plus intelligible c'est
une photo qui a été prise à la suite du
meeting de lille ça m'a fait du bien de
voir qu'il y avait des politiciens qui
pouvait être aussi proches de leurs
militants et aussi reconnaissante
envers de la politique correctement une
coalition qui leur ait perdu collage
préfère du tractage il faut aller au
contact des gens parce que arrivé sans
avoir fait tout ce travail de terrain
pour moi on n'a pas une légitimité
suffisante
[Musique]
banier risque c'est tout simplement que
îles des antilles faa ou des
groupuscules qui a ri ou simplement des
passants qui viennent et qu'ils soient
pas d'accord avec le fait qu'on
soutienne zemmour et puis qui puisse
nous agresser verbalement mais
physiquement aussi donc ça peut vraiment
aller très loin
ok elle c'est un spot il ya vraiment
beaucoup de passage avec des voitures
donc ça permet vraiment de donner de la
visibilité à des affiches de toute façon
elles sont retirées très rapidement mais
là où le match a arraché devant moi vous
redire l'affichage quelque chose de
primordial lors d'une campagne va se
remettre ça montre qu'on est présents
sur un territoire c'est un signe qui sut
elle est ce important
vive la france on sait pas trop si cette
fringante
en face d'un côté cour
et il ya deux jours à belfort sont
adressés les militants ont fait
attention
les époux ils t'attendent
qui
fait partie de mes mots à maux
aller à gaza gauche
qui se ramène à plusieurs et qu'ensuite
c'est ça en fait après il appelle etc il
ya plusieurs voitures qui arrivent et là
c'est la mienne commence alors on y va
pour défaillir mettais trop de temps
mais qui rare entre elles à t'imaginer
mais qui viennent
pas du tout sécurisé on est à côté de la
rue on a une visibilité énorme donc là
en semaine c'est un engagement mais
encore une fois la politique c'est plus
qu'une vocation c'est une passion et je
pense que les gens qui s'investissent et
qu'ils en ont envie et c'est qu'ils sont
passionnés aussi on est tous derrière un
candidat il a besoin de soutien on est
la jeunesse on est la force militante
derrière lui donc si nous on s'engage
pas qui va le faire
[Musique]